right now before I get to the whole
greatest coefficient idea let's just
rehearse what's a simple expansion like
say 1 plus X let's raise it to the power
4 hopefully your knowing your Pascal's
triangle numbers well enough to do this
off my heart and buy like you see now by
the way while that why the X is second
it's so that we get the X powers
increasing
yeah so first time it's 1
what specifically that's 1 to the power
4 right that's just 1 ok next one next
term along in Pascal's triangle in this
row is 4 matches up to the power it
always matches up turns out ok for
you've got another 3 lots of 1 just 1
and then you get one term X and then it
just grows from there yeah plus 4 you
come back down alright so simple
expansion ok are you sorry ok now if I'm
looking for the greatest coefficient in
this series it's really easy ok because
no matter how big this power is it's
always going to be the middle term right
or the middle pair of terms if I had an
E vitamin even number okay right because
they're equal to each other like 10 10
so if you like you could sort of draw it
like this the coefficients they kind of
just rise and then fall and they're
symmetrical because Pascal's triangle
symmetrical right so if I want to make
out the greatest co-efficient this case
no problems but when you change the
actual binomial you get some problems ok
because that two and that three that are
inside the brackets right they're going
to come into play here and they're going
to change what the numbers are right
they're going to muck around with the
coefficients so work out with me let's
write the full on expansion ok you're
the one for six for one that's still
gonna be the same okay so in fact I'm
just going to write that you
all right now what happens with these
twos right well I start off with a whole
bunch of them I start off with four two
two then three dots or two then two
lines and it decreases right so we're
going to get to the four two cubed 2
squared
just one lot of - and no more bottom to
that now with the three X's I have no
Lots here then I've got one life we are
three X to power should have made more
space I've got two lots here you're
getting the idea three lots and on the
end I have at least one okay
so let's work out what these numbers are
16 that's to the 4 right 4 times 8 is 32
and times 3 is 96 96 lot 7x all right 6
times 4 24 times 9 260 squared 4 times 2
is 8 8 times 3 cubed is 8 times 27 which
is 216 and then 3 to the power 4 is 81
okay now what's going on what's the
greatest coefficient
well um it's the middle term but it's
not just the middle term is it it's this
term and this term that's over towards
the right they're equal to each other in
this case okay so you can sort of see my
sort of pyramid that I had here right
it's still a pyramid but it's kind of
Leaning right the terms still increase
and then decrease but they've kind of
been done kind of been skewed over 12
this direction okay now what will happen
if I change these numbers right suppose
I went to plus 5x now what would you
expect to happen
the coefficient and their size are going
to go even more this way why because
this these increasing coefficients right
the reason they increase is because of
the three right
you've got what the verse three is over
here and so that's why you've got any
one and less threes here and so on so
I'm going to have the mush fives over on
this end okay now just a savior bit of
time and went and expanded these so you
get this that's still 16
this is 160 that's 1600 that's and
that's six five okay so this time it's
unambiguous now it's like two terms
sharing the crown is just this one I'm
going further right now you can probably
imagine just for the sake of argument
right I can play around with the numbers
and I can make the greatest coefficient
wherever I like okay so for instance I
just went in did nine just for the sake
of it and you get this 16 288 nineteen
forty four and six five six one okay
sure this time because I've made that
second term in the binomial so much
larger that's why this guy takes over
doesn't matter what all these other guys
are the nines just too big okay now in
these cases because I've only got five
terms and the numbers are to
astronomical right I really can if I
just want the greatest coefficient I can
work out the whole expansion okay but
this is going to be a real pain as I
increase these numbers and these numbers
okay and you can bet that number one you
would get such easy numbers okay and
your exams are coming but number two
even if you do obviously it'll be much
faster if rather writing the whole thing
I could just go straight to the one and
know which one was the greatest okay so
how do I do that I want to enjoy
attention back to the fact that you've
got this pyramid shape right even though
the numbers are skewed they're still
increasing and then decreasing go far
enough right so that one doesn't
actually there's no you know I haven't
I've gone too far so I know I can get
through the greatest term when the next
terms coefficient starts to decrease
right so if this is like term nor term
one term two twenty three twenty four
okay when I know that coefficient the
coefficient of term 3 is greater than
term for I know I've got there right
that's going to be the greatest one
that's the first instance where happens
okay so what I want to work out is if I
say let see on term n right let's call
that the coefficient of the nth term
okay what I want is for that term right
that coefficient to be greater than or
at least equal to they can be equal
that's all right
to the next one right
you should probably call it because I've
already got ends yeah
so I want it to be greater than the next
term over which is our plus 1 okay so
how do I work this out let's take an
example and let's take one where it
really would be impractical to work out
what every term is okay so let me push
the power up and twelve terms how can I
work out what the greatest coefficient
or which which term it lands on okay
well what is the what is the nth term in
this case okay um the nth term T or the
after right what's it equal to
hmm how do I get these numbers well I
had that binomial at the front right
that one four six four one what is it
what choose what eleven that's the row
and then I want the earth term a lot
right so it's going to be 11 shoes are
out the front okay all right then I'm
going to have a bit of this term in a
bit of that term but I'll sorry yeah
okay sure um yeah all right sorry I see
what you mean um is what we're trying to
what's the problem is whether you call
the first term T naught or T 1 right
that's that's the issue I'm going to go
with this being the which turn my after
let's let it let's start with tone 1 I
guess because otherwise you
no actually no I do want to start with
zero don't know I do want to start at
zero because the first term is 11 choose
naught right so because that's what
gives me one I mean this okay if we
started start at T naught and that's
going to be all right okay firm totally
confused let's get going
I'm going to get some twos inside with
three X's how many do I get of each well
we started off by saying you know the
first term has all of them right so that
would normally be like to the power of
11 okay
so as I go along I go 11 10 9 8 start at
11 and then I subtract however many
terms along I am right so 11 minus R so
in the case of R equals 0 ok I'm going
to have 11 shoes not which is 1 and then
I'm going to have to the power of 11
minus 0 so that's why it'll be to live
and that's the biggest term for true
then I'm going to have the other guys of
3 to the power 3 to the 3x right how
many of those are there well it's the
rest of its the leftovers right because
these have to add up to 11 yeah okay now
let's just expand that out a little bit
just a teeny bit because what I'm really
after is the coefficient right I want I
want the numbers I want these 216 SAT
ones and so on okay so I've brought out
the X and I've kept these all on one
part because that's the number that's
the actual value that I'm after okay
so therefore that coefficient or that
earth term is just those bits
without the X okay now by extension I
can say well what's the coefficient of
the next term right follow logic with me
it's not going to be 11 shoes are any
more because I'm one term over so do be
11 choose R plus one okay
now this power to write it's going to be
to the power of 11 minus R plus 1 so I'm
going 11 minus R minus 1
sound okay now I know I could put that
one in there and make it a 10 but it's
actually going to be no juice to us
really to have that simplified you'll
see why in a second okay last bit how
many lots of 3 will there be there will
be R plus 1 terms okay all right now
there's my our coefficient there's my
office one coefficient and here's the
inner quality I want to satisfy this is
what will give me the greatest
coefficient okay so even though they
look terrible
let's suffer more then and in order to
actually get some things cancelling here
okay instead of having 11 choose
Beauvoir I'm going to bring it back to a
factorial notation okay so let's do the
left hand side first I'll lower the
factorial on what ah factorial 11 minus
R factorial okay
then I've got two to the one of the most
are and 3dr okay I want that coffee
shirt to be greater than or at least
equal to in the case of one like that
the next one over
okay so 11 factorial on hmm this is R
plus 1 and this is 11 minus R minus 1
okay yeah
2
and three okay it canceling pen ready
because you can see how much of this is
in common with both sides right for
instance right off the bat you can see
11 factorial okay so let's get rid of
that guy okay ah I love factorial here
over here I've got that plus one
factorial now what's the difference
between those just just the R plus one
that that last term along the N so all
these guys go and this factorial goes I
just end up with that last little lemon
- r 11 minus R minus 1 what's the
difference between them again just the
last term well it was just the 11 minus
R okay so all of that factorial grows
and just the factorial part of that goes
leaving the last bit okay - to learn
minus R and to the 11 minus R minus 1
which one's bigger this one's bigger
right because this is minus one so it's
divided by two
once okay so the difference between
these two is two okay you see now why
there wasn't much point to make it 10
minus R because I was just going to do
this anyway whatever number it was okay
one more time three of the UH plus 1 and
a 3 to the are the difference is 3 to
the 1 okay so this guy goes and I'm left
with that 3 all right so what do I
actually have after the dust settles
I've got to 11 minus R and then I've got
three on our plus one okay
so cross multiply bring the three are
over bring the 2 sorry 2 over divide
through and that's going to be six and a
fifth okay
now remember what am I actually trying
to find out ah corresponds to you which
term is it going to be right that I
actually get to it and then all the
terms after that start getting smaller
and smaller and smaller
so ours gotten bigger than 6 and 1/5
it's got to be an integer actually right
and so therefore
seven right now I actually haven't
answered the question yet right
the question was what is the greatest
coefficient okay so the coefficient of
that term okay is equal to when I write
down there it is
okay eleven choose seven to the 4/3 to
the seven okay yeah oh you mean like
like that actually more I was thinking
about whether I should put natural but
it's easier than that snowball just
leave it there um now this is no Makia I
where'd it down I actually got it my
calculator and I think it is this yeah
do you have to write that down like
actually evaluate it the answer is
sometimes if the exam was written
properly the assess was written properly
they'll tell you what they want it in
but sometimes as you can imagine these
numbers just spiral off and they're not
actually this is how many digits that's
eight digits just carefully this can
handle that but if I made the numbers a
bit bigger you know your calculator
explore it right so as a result and as
you're seeing the excitement
if you usually we just get the answer
like this because that all the
information is there right you can see
where they got it from and it's like
what is it equal to
it doesn't really matter right
occasionally a question will say give us
the actual number but usually that's
okay
you